oh i don't care what you think they look
like i care what they are and you guys
what no dude i'm still pressed about
this
because the whole internet is
gaslighting me billy eilish spent her
weekend having a
total meltdown over the color of her
sneakers and let me warn you
the whole thing feels very 2015. what
color is the dress
you know the dress
tell me these are the colors you think
that this shoe is tell me that's what
you think
tell me that's what you think you think
that that color
is that coat please
how is it pink how is this pink dude
god you wanna yup we're doing this again
dude here's the thing bro it all started
when the grammy winner decided to take
part in a little q a
on instagram the 18 year old revealed
she had voted earlier that day
and that she had a new song coming out
in november
then one fan threw it back to simpler
times
asking billy if she thought the dress
was blue and black
or white and gold yeah apparently we're
still on that
i never in a million years would have
thought this should happen billy's
response
cannot stress it enough it is blue
and gold that's what it is blue and gold
watch i also seriously don't give a [ __ ]
if they figured out that it actually was
a certain color
i don't give a [ __ ] in that picture it's
blue and gold
so that settles that and while she was
on the topic
billy started another great debate you
guys are all
my dad years ago i was wearing these
shoes
and my dad's like wow those shoes are so
cool what are those like
pink and white okay but um i see pink
and white
i don't know what happened to you guys
in your childhoods
but
pink and white
pink and white that's what you're going
with
pink and white
i'd love to tell you that the whole
thing ended with that but
it didn't like not at all if i think too
hard i get all up in my head
billy searched for the shoes on the
internet and proved the sneakers
are in fact mint and white yeah and it
kept going
i see p i see green now but this is the
real shoe i see green
this still looks real shoe it's been the
real show all the time
no but it's not a photo of it it's the
actual shoe in my hands
and going i see pink and green
and some white pink
green white that's not a white white
it's a pink white and going
up to anything else
that's more close to that than it is
that
wouldn't you agree wouldn't you agree
yeah
and then just like that i started seeing
green
god that's so weird you're gonna sit
here and tell me that that
and that is the same as that
that's what you're gonna tell me right
now do you think those are the same
colors you think that this is this
and this is this is that really what you
think
hey you know what i can't do this again
i'm still shook from 2015.
my heart can't handle it i'm out bye
so we all know that i'm right here even
if you see something else
you know that i'm right underneath it
all right
and real quick before you keep arguing
or whatever the
the entire internet's been calling me
fat for a week so let me have this
let me have this